Alec Baldwin can you break down this his
wife's accent thing happening this is
what her accent is I'm not going to say
anything to you you know that so please
leave my family in peace
and can you show me the version of her
that doesn't have it and I think part
in shape before I have a baby
that's crazy that's not crazy to you we
should talk like this low-key is she
faking talking white maybe she speaks
Spanish she's faking talking white you
go to La and they all faking talking
Kardashians to your point Spanish people
aren't white she's just doing a
completely different ethnicity nah she's
Spanish yeah what do you mean she's
Spanish bro she's Spanish yeah she's
fine so it's okay yeah because he's
doing a white person's accent come on
bro wait I gotta go away